welcome to this video playing Hester
best from Thailand okay horses are best
and he's got a horse picture in his
profile okay um let's see um modern
defense or pills and some about the same
love interesting near this advanced this
is recommended in the repertoire for
chrome Lake books no repertoire for
white according to chrome lake by like
some like a Leafman I tried to learn
that for white but I failed just too too
many variations to to memorize ok we
have a position type that should be
somewhat better for Wyatt he simply got
more space how to how to play if I take
on da fé it will take with the pawn
that's um that's a problem maybe I can
get some counter play here Queen B 6
Queen a 6 something like that
yeah it's definitely a position where I
would prefer to be white but it's too
late I'm I'm in this now how to how to
improve yeah I probably should play
rupee 8 soon so that after a possible ed
5cd 585 the pony 7s erm is protected aha
so I got him provoked to take not that
it is necessarily great for me but it
seems like something that white did not
necessarily want to do ok glad so still
see for hang if I would have taken with
the Pawnee I think about a play to e5
this um didn't look too great ok so what
now it's got a possible 95 coming mmm
can maybe just take it let's cover let's
cover e7 it's hard to do without the
smooth b5 ok this is also possibility I
didn't think it was so dangerous but
maybe I'm I'm under estimating it
all right let's exchange some pieces
this would help it takes on d 797 of the
c3 hanging I don't think that e5 was the
most dangerous way to play yeah this is
of course also possible I thought that
this type of structure should be okay
but that's interesting take him yeah 195
well i only recommend with bishop jakes
but it's probably a good anyway I mean
not good in sense of better for black
patent 95 versus as an ok move yeah I
have Bishop g4 here all night is 6 and
night to deform oh this is not too bad
maybe him he gives up the exchange hmm
maybe I should have played it
differently yeah I thought giving up the
exchange was possible interesting this
is no just ok for me I think I have a
good night Ian let's see let's see f6
and d5 mmm c5 is probably I can go see
five actually of course I can go see if
I if you cannot take because of 92 and
see if it's e5 is a desirable move it
blocks his majority here ok so there's
some some sort of trick possible I don't
think so let's cover and intend to play
f6 into e5 cementing the snide
yeah come on let's let's play quickly if
I he might go a form I don't need to do
it immediately okay maybe just a sick
son yeah I don't I don't need to play
five I mean this is night is nicely
positioned anyway let's see table before
then slowly improve ok
hmm not sure hmm yeah how to how to
actually get ahead here
and I don't I don't see a good way to
make any progress it's not so easy check
I 9292 I'm a [ __ ] of course he couldn't
play Brooke h3 because of this this move
sometimes
ah unbelievable if I would have take
maybe maybe I could have taken you have
got night f5 which I forgot about very
stupid
check check yeah we got to an end game
sharp end game yeah I think I'm actually
actually okay yeah yeah cannot you find
a time warning check yeah night i think
i'm missing so many simple winds at the
moment it's really it's really not nice
check check check check check mate yeah
I mean this is I think the relatively
deserved result despite many mistakes
around here it started to to get okay
for me mean I think he must take it 6cm
this is clearly clearly the best move
and play this position which is
interesting he suddenly has good
compensation for the exchange this is
this piece now can get very strong fe in
this move Queen g4 this is a good good
position for white at least it's
interesting and this is just clearly
better for black with the strong night
here why does some widest in serious
trouble long-term I didn't find a good
way to to make progress though maybe
some other way to pile up on the b3 porn
I was mostly marking time
yeah and he Air Force 92 wine check and
here i can maybe take i was a slight
thinking I was thinking that this is
good for white because something like
this Sam check but maybe I can even go
here why I've got this move and this is
still Jam to still a problem now I can
go here though this I didn't consider at
all so I could have taken the bishop
maybe yeah he is it gets very hectic of
course the night is still the better
piece I mean this is quite clear check
check Jimmy yeah yeah the comp gives me
a decisive edge I wasn't sure really it
looked nice because I'm quicker with the
attack relief but it's also due to some
circumstantial things like this tempo
and so on so maybe he needs to play that
but if i get the pawn it's very good for
me check I could have taken the bishop
you but ok this is probably also we know
only at 20 seconds so I'm glad to have
played it quickly yeah here White is
losing on f2 complicated stuff the the
most interesting position is really this
one way needs to set the exchange but
somehow didn't do it ok thanks for
watching